wir leben in einem reichen land und
müssen trotzdem über armut sprechen über
kinderarmut zum beispiel über zwei
millionen kinder leben in familien in
denen das geld oft nicht reicht darum
ging es heute auch bei der nationalen
armutskonferenz die seit gestern in
berlin getagt hat und darum soll es
heute auch bei uns gehen wenn ihr fragen
dazu habt dann postet sie gerne hier
unten in die kommentare
wir wollen außerdem über armut bei
jungen erwachsenen sprechen denn die
zahlen die zeigen keine andere gruppe
ist so von armut bedroht wie die 18 bis
25 jährigen romanesco war hat einen
jungen mann getroffen denen das betrifft
[Musik]
ja ich bin unter gucken ob das haus
bekannt ihr habt straße gelandet weil er
öfters von meinen eltern habe einfach
abgehauen bin ich hatte keine lust mehr
auf das auf diesen haushalt soll wir zu
viel stress dann bin ich abgehauen kam
in das heim bin dann kam es nicht
dann bin ich da mit 18 das letzte mal
abgehauen und seitdem hat das jugendamt
so gesagt nee ist nicht mehr den
unterstützen wir nicht erst jetzt
sozialamt fähig das 18
seitdem bin schon gekauft wird auf der
straße ja ich gehe manchmal stören
also ich glaub betteln und das hilft mir
hilf mir durch das bringt mich durch den
tag zu kritisch main hessen
wir wollen hier nicht weit von der
partymeile berlin für rein theoretisch
und das kann manchmal total besoffen
menschen und denken sich einfach nur
weil wir auf der straße sind weil wir im
leben anscheinend laut normalos nicht
klarkommen und schlagen zu müssen wir
natürlich so denken die können wenig so
und dann gibt es immer wieder stress und
manche zieht ein messer der andere zieht
ein teleskopschlagstock der andere zieht
seine quarzhandschuhe an meine sozial
sozialamt betreute die gesagt komm
hatten wir dich und betreutes wohnen
kein problem da war ich da uns von dem
moment an musste ich täglich termine
einhalten was ich nicht hoffe mein gott
ich bin auf der straße ich bin draußen
täglich
und dann schaffe ich es auch bestimmt
nicht um 6 uhr aufzustehen mich frisch
zu machen und um 8 fertig zu sein oder
jetzt wird erst kalt und ich habe schon
so einige situation im winter lebt wo
ich einfach unter der warschauer ist
unter der warschauer brücke da saß und
einfach richtig gefroren habe weil ich
noch so einen halben sommer schlafsack
hatte und vielleicht klappt eine kurze
deckung hatten auch gesagt
leider kann man sich auch hergekommen
davon so ja die haben noch dicke
schlafsäcke und sowas das hat mir schon
öfters leben das leben gerettet
ich habe mein größter wunsch zeit ist
einfach eine wohnung zu haben keine
arbeit zu haben um achte bei der arbeit
zu sein 16 uhr wieder frei zu sein und
darüber spreche ich jetzt live mit
eckhard baumann dem leiter von
straßenkinder ev
das ist ein verein der sich um kinder
und jugendliche in not aber auch eben in
obdachlosigkeit kümmert guten abend herr
baumann
hallo herr baumann wenn junge menschen
wie zum beispiel cookie zu ihnen kommen
was brauchen die am meisten und wie
helfen sie denen
also leute wie der koki oder eigentlich
wie jeder der hier in der anlaufstellen
kommt brauche erstmal ein offenes ohr
und mehr herzliche annahme so das
vertrauen gebildet wird und deswegen ist
unsere arbeit auch sehr beziehungs
orientiert wir kümmern uns um die jungen
leute und nehmen sie erst mal an so
genau wie sie sind und gibt es dann also
wir haben es gab schon gesehen
kleiderkammer zum beispiel gibt es was
gibt es noch für angebote also hier in
der warschauer straße 17 und in der
kopernikusstraße da gehört da haben wir
verschiedene angebote zum einen gibt es
hier eine handy ladestation wir haben
auch schlafsäcke hier wir haben eine
kleiderkammer wir haben
ein begegnungscafé wir haben durch
möglichkeit eine waschmaschine
beratungsmöglichkeiten und ja und wir
machen auch viel mit integrations
freizeiten
das heißt wir gehen mit den
straßenkindern mit den straßen
jugendlichen auch mal für ein wochenende
oder für eine woche aus der stadt raus
so dass sie wechseln von drogen druck
und von dem druck des alltags und mit
der power die sie dann durch solche
freizeiten gewinnen ist es wesentlich
einfacher zusammen nach
lösungsmöglichkeiten zu finden in berlin
zb bei der wohnungssuche jetzt können
sie sich ja nicht nur um junge menschen
die auf der straße leben sondern zum
beispiel auch um kinder die anderen
familien leben wo nicht viel geld da ist
wie finden finden die den den weg zu
ihnen
ja also wir haben in marzahn ein angebot
das heißt kinder und jugendhaus wolle
dort betreuen wir bis zu 120 kinder pro
tag und in marzahn ist es einfach so in
diesem sozialen raum in dem wir arbeiten
da ist die soziale struktur schon von
vornherein so dass wir zwischen 50 und
80 kinder haben die deren familien von
hartz iv leben
ich habe jetzt schon mal ein bisschen
einblick in die kommentare geworfen
und hier wird auf jeden fall zum
beispiel bei facebook darüber diskutiert
was überhaupt genau armut bedeutet also
es gibt ja immer schon diesen
diskussionen um den armuts begriff und
auch um dieses armutsrisiko schreibt zum
beispiel reiner hoffmann der mangel an
geld ist nicht zwangsläufig mit armut
gleichzusetzen er hält deswegen diese
zahl von zwei millionen kindern die
armut gefährdet sind für nicht passend
diese definition wenn ich hab sie mal
frage ganz unabhängig davon wie das
vielleicht offiziell definiert wird
wo fängt für sie armut an wenn sie jetzt
so über ihre tägliche arbeit nachdenken
also armut hat viele facetten und
insofern eine wesentliche facette ist
tatsächlich dass das
durchschnittseinkommen dass eine familie
zur verfügung hat und gerade
alleinerziehende sind verstärkt
armutsgefährdet insofern halte ich das
schon für logisch und verflüssigt dass
man es erst mal daran aufhängt gerade
wenn es um politische rahmenbedingungen
geht um das was die politik tun soll
allerdings ist tatsächlich auch so dass
armut sehr oft auch eine emotionale
armut oder von emotionaler armut
begleitet wird und armut kinderarmut
geht oft einher mit bildungsarmut auch
das zuhause vielleicht nicht so
vorgelesen wird das ja das manchmal auch
vielleicht so ein bisschen die nestwärme
fehlt es gibt es natürlich auch und
deswegen sind wir auch da im kinder
jugend haus ball und nehmen die kinder
auf und nehmen sie an so wie sie sind
sie sprechen das schon ein punkt an auf
denen ich auch zu sprechen kommen wollte
nämlich die frage woran worunter leiden
die kinder am meisten sind das wirklich
nur materielle dinge oder ist das zb
auch ausgrenzung das jetzt nicht
angenommen werden von anderen kindern
vielleicht weil sie nicht die tollen
markenklamotten haben oder ähnliches ja
also genau also gesellschaftliche
teilhabe dass das ist so ein thema was
was für diese kinder sehr schwieriges
weil man sich eben keinen kinobesuch
leisten kann oder weil man sich eben
keine markenklamotten leisten kann oder
vielleicht noch nicht mal ein paar
ordentliche winterstiefel und dadurch
steht man natürlich immer ein bisschen
abseits auch in der schule in der klasse
und das ist nicht so einfach zu
kompensieren für diese kinder
herr baumann wir wollen uns noch mal die
aktuelle situation von armut gefährdeten
kindern hier in deutschland genauer
anschauen und nina niebergall hat einmal
ein paar fakten zusammengetragen
es fehlt ihnen an regelmäßigen warmen
mahlzeiten an warmer kleidung an geld
für sportvereine schulausflüge es geht
um jedes fünfte kind in deutschland 2,4
millionen kinder wachsenden haushalten
auf die weniger als 60 prozent des
durchschnittlichen nettoeinkommens haben
knapp 28.000 600 euro pro jahr sind das
etwa bei einer familie mit zwei kindern
diese kinder gelten per definition als
von armut oder sozialer ausgrenzung
bedroht etwa weil die eltern arbeitslos
sind oder aber allein erziehend denn
allein erziehende arbeiten häufig in
teilzeit haben dann oft keine
betreuungsmöglichkeit für ihr kind
müssen scheidungskosten tragen
sechs von zehn kinder von
alleinerziehenden sind von armut bedroht
laut einer studie der bertelsmann
stiftung
besonders gefährdet sind auch kinder aus
familien mit drei oder mehr kindern die
armutsquote liegt hier bei 30 prozent
kinderarmut in deutschland darauf
reagierte die politik erst in diesem
jahr mit zwei wohlklingenden gesetzen
den sogenannten starke familiengesetz
und dem gute kita gesetz die sollen
weniger wohlhabende familien entlasten
aber reicht das ja genau diese frage die
würde ich gerne an sie weitergeben herr
baumann reicht das was die politik tut
hier kommen nämlich auch schon so ein
paar kommentare zum beispiel bei twitter
von slobodan der das gefühl hat dass
sogar seit jahren hilfen gestrichen
werden in den städten
also ich finde persönlich dass es
wichtig ist dass die politik die
rahmenbedingungen so steckt das dass das
geld bei den kindern ankommt das ist
weil es besteht immer die gefahr dass
eltern zum beispiel die vielleicht sucht
man suchtmittel gefährdet sind dass sie
das geld für andere dinge ausgeben
insofern ist es mir ein anliegen oder
ich fand es wichtig dass das geld
tatsächlich bei den kindern ankommt und
dass es unbürokratisch dort ankommt und
dass es nachhaltig und nach
weil ich dort ankommt und das ist
eigentlich die die wesentliche grund
forderung von uns an die politik allein
mehr geld zu geben dass das es nicht die
lösung sondern es muss dafür gesorgt
werden dass das geld tatsächlich bei den
kids ankommt jetzt gibt's ja auch das
argument dass es hier auch ein bisschen
in manchen kommentaren dass es mit
durchscheint na ja die leute müssen ja
auch nur zum amt gehen es ist so einfach
ich kenne jetzt die frage nicht genau
die leute müssen wissen sie wir angehen
und und beantragen genau um zu
beantragen also es gibt ja sogar jetzt
bei dem neuen gesetz geht ja sogar die
bundesregierung davon aus dass gar nicht
alle die sogar anspruch hätten ist
beantragen am ende ja so viele eltern
die haben tatsächlich also die müssen an
dieser stelle und an jener stelle
anträge ausfüllen und manche sind
tatsächlich auch überfordert damit
deswegen nehmen wir die eltern teilweise
auch an der hand und helfen ihnen beim
ausfüllen dieser anträge und vor allen
dingen ist es noch nicht gebündelt genug
all diese maßnahmen und unsere meinung
nach müssten diese maßnahmen gebündelt
werden so dass sie wirklich beim kind
ankommen und so dass man nicht drei vier
oder fünf anträge ausfüllen muss sondern
das einer genügt es wird ja oft auch
gesagt armut die vererbt sich also wären
eine arme familie geboren wird der hat
kaum chancen da wieder rauszukommen
erleben sie so was auch das ist
tatsächlich so dass armut vererbt wird
und insofern bearbeiten wir sehr stark
dagegen indem wir zum beispiel sehr viel
auf bildung setzen sehr viele
bildungsangebote haben indem wir
gemeinsam mit den kindern ihre talente
entdecken indem wir sie fördern und
indem wir ihn zum beispiel auch
berufsmöglichkeiten zeigen jenseits von
dem was ihn aus ihrem unmittelbaren
umfeld
kennen also wir machen mit denen
unternehmensbesuche wir schließen die
auch in firmen ein sodass sie praktika
stopp machen können einfach um den
horizont zu erweitern und das ist sehr
sehr wichtig dass man diese kits an der
hand nimmt so dass man diesen armuts
kreislauf durchbrechen
jetzt kommen hier zum beispiel auch
solche kommentare zum beispiel bei
twitter das schreibt jemand es gibt echt
andere diskussionen die viel wichtiger
sind
wir sprechen hier über kinderarmut und
über mehr als zwei millionen kinder
bleiben wir da offenbar zu wenig darüber
dass leute annehmen dass das unwichtig
sein
also ich denke wir reden noch zu wenig
darüber und ich denke wir wir handeln
auch noch zu wenig und ich denke denke
dass wir wesentlich mehr darüber reden
müssten sie sagen jetzt es wird zu wenig
gehandelt jetzt muss man auch mal
festhalten
ihr verein straßenkinder ev finanziert
sich durch spenden ist nicht staatlich
was müsste denn noch mehr passieren was
könnte es dennoch der angebote geben
also zum einen glaube ich dass wir
tatsächlich solche träger wie wir also
wie wir einer sind dass man den auch
staatliche mittel zur verfügung stellen
sollte also das sind wir auch staatliche
gelder bekommen
das finde ich sehr wichtig zum einen
glaube ich auch dass das wir schon
erkennen müssen dass allein durch durch
mehr geld wird die wir dieses problem
langfristig nicht gelöst sondern wir
müssen uns tatsächlich um unsere kinder
wieder kümmern ganz persönlich und da
denke ich es auch jeder jeder gefordert
auch der vielleicht auch die die keine
kinder
dass wir dass wir uns um kinder kümmern
weil kinder sind unsere zukunft und
unsere gegenwart auch schon jetzt haben
wir viel über die probleme gesprochen
gibt es dann auch biografien die ihnen
mut machen also junge menschen den sie
zum beispiel geholfen haben und dies
dann wirklich geschafft haben aus der
armut herauszukommen
ja klar also es gibt jede menge von von
beispielen von jugendlichen unserer
kinder im jugendhaus bäume gibt es seit
fast zehn jahren straßenkinder vorgibt
zeit
20 jahren und wir haben natürlich schon
eine ganze menge von von biographien
erlebt wo dann jugendliche wo sie eine
ausbildung geschafft haben wo sie wo es
irgend weg gemacht haben auch leute die
tatsächlich ganz unten waren die schon
mit also ein mädchen zum beispiel die ja
ich dies mit 9 von zu hause abgehauen
hat auf der straße gelebt in köln auf
der domplatte und sie ist deswegen
abgehauen weil ihr vater ihr stiefvater
er im affekt sie so geschlagen hat das
dass der kiefer gebrochen ist dann ist
sie abgehauen
seit jahre lang auf der straße gelebt
und wir haben sie dann kennengelernt in
berlin am ostbahnhof bei lidl in der
tiefgarage und haben mir geholfen und
haben sie begleitet und sie hat einen
schulabschluss gemacht hat
sozialassistentin gelernt hat es mit 1
bestanden
und dann haben sie ermutigt mensch
lernen doch erzieherin und auch deshalb
sie geschafft mit 1 bis 2 und ist dann
erzielen geworden ob bis dahin dass die
stellvertretende kita-leiterin geworden
ist und mittlerweile ist sie verheiratet
und mutter von zwei kindern und und das
ein paradebeispiel dafür was passieren
kann wenn man wenn man leute weil man
leuten hilft wenn man ihnen auch eine
zweite und dritte chance gibt und ich
denke darauf kommt es auch darauf an
dass man jemand nicht wenn er einmal
versagt und liegen bleibt dass man den
ligen lässt sondern dass man den
wirklich eine zweite und dritte chance
gibt und das machen wir bei uns im
verein also hilfe ist wichtig und lohnt
sich
eckhard baumann ich freue mich sehr dass
sie sich heute die zeit für uns genommen
haben und ich bedanke mich natürlich
auch bei euch für die rege diskussion
fürs zu sehen und wir würden uns sehr
freuen wenn ihr beim nächsten live
stream auch dabei sein bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann interessiert euch
vielleicht auch dieser hier
da ging es um die hartz iv sanktionen
oder ihr schaut mal hier rein
da haben wir darüber gesprochen ob die
grundrente auf kosten der jungen geht
oder ihr lasst einfach hier in abu dhabi
das wird uns freuen